- All right, your ears look good.
So that should be the
end of this physical.
- Oh, great.
- Yeah, there is one last thing
that we actually have to do.
- Okay.
- Ahhh.
- Yeah...
No, I don't know.
- It's time for the main show.
(laughs)
- What, what do you mean.
- The reason why we're all here.
You know (zip) (zip) (phh) (cough)
- What was that you were doing?
Like, air traffic signals?
(laughs)
- I need you to drop 'em.
- Drop what?
- Drop 'em like it's hot.
- Drop what like it's hot?
- Drop 'em and cough 'em.
Drop your trousers, let me see your tower.
- Is that a medical term?
- I get it,
cradle your ladle.
Lower your drawbridge.
Let's see if these lemons
actually make lemonade.
(clears throat)
- Cock-a-doodle-doo!
It's berry picking season.
Look, this isn't easy,
but I need to see your peasy.
I hope you use Febreze,
because I need to squeeze.
- Squeeze what, I don't.
- It's time to part the forbidden curtain.
At ease, soldier.
Lower your weapons.
Look man, I'm on a questicle.
Crikey mate, I'm going down under.
Crikey, it bit me.
No, you don't get it on that one?
All right.
- Four words.
- Right.
- First word.
I'm not good at this game.
Doctor, what do you need to see?
- Uh, I need to check your pu.
- My pulse?
- Uh, no, but it begins with a P.
- My prostate?
Pancreas?
- Your pee aah nuts.
Your pine nuts.
- My pine nuts?
- Yeah, say it a little faster.
- Doctor, I don't know what you're saying.
- I need to grab your penis balls.
Your testicles.
- Then why didn't you just say that?
- Pine nuts?
You didn't get it with pine nuts?